This is really interesting, a YouTube creator
named Shuen Head, who has even more YouTube
subscribers than we do, if you can imagine
that, it's hard to believe, but she does.
She went to a Trump rally and she asked Trump,
do you think burning the American flag should
be legal or illegal?
OK, and then there are subsequent questions.
So let's look at some initial clips and start
to get a sense of this.
I would say no, no, you know, no.
No, I do not believe that it should be legal.
However, I stress I believe in freedom of
speech.
However, I feel that, well, it's not very
patriotic way.
Of course not, it's a sacred, sacred part
of the Boy Scouts, I learned that to.
Retire a flag.
So I don't think it's like an airline.
I think this plus me, I got you, but I know
you don't think you should be leaving.
Don't be like.
I believe in the First Amendment.
I would not do it, but I would support the
right for do.
I think when you make it illegal, you're going
nuts.
I believe that as a First Amendment right
that you do have the right.
So I'm aware of it disgusts me that people
who do so some interesting responses there
and it's fine that not everybody has the same
opinion.
Some say you should not be allowed to burn
the American flag.
Some say that you should.
Some say that you should, but they wouldn't
do it or it should be legal, but they find
it disgusting.
The funny and the interesting ones are the
people who say it should be illegal.
But I support the First Amendment.
I support the First Amendment.
But when it comes to burning the flag, that's
just a bit too far.
Now, interestingly, the topic with a bunch
of these folks becomes the Black Lives Matter
flag.
As you might know, you may have heard that
some right wingers were cited for burning
a Black Lives Matter flag at a church during
a prior protest.
The issue is it's not an analogous situation.
The issue with the Black Lives Matter flag
was that it was someone's private property
and it was taken from church property.
Could have been a flag of anything that what
was relevant was not that it was a Black Lives
Matter flag.
There's certainly nothing sacred or protected
about a Black Lives Matter flag.
So there's some confusion here.
I really don't like the American flag on the
brown boys burned beyond you.
And naturally, it should definitely be the
American flag on your property that perhaps
it should be legal.
Well, if you can, then you should be able
to burn the, you know, the Black Lives Matter
flag and not get arrested for whatever the
black flag.
If you steal someone's flag and burn it, that's
a whole different story.
Now, of course, that's exactly what was at
issue in the Black Lives Matter flag incident
a few months ago.
Someone's flag was stolen while people were
trespassing onto the church's property.
So a lot of these folks seizing on that to
try to create a an analogous situation where
where there isn't one.
In this next clip, you have military veterans
who disagree with each other on this issue.
We're going to hear from vets who have different
perspectives on this.
Do you think it should be legal to burn the
American flag?
Absolutely.
Yeah, because the Constitution says you can.
Yes, yes, yes.
Yes.
And also, free speech, censored at all.
I mean, it's a First Amendment issue.
Mr Barnett, I suppose I support the right.
I certainly know the military to support gay
rights to.
A lot of weird things I agree with.
No, no, no, I'm sorry.
That's not for us.
Oh.
Warning it should not be legal, not in this
country, definitely does not have to learn
the Furstenberg's.
Oh, no, no, no, I think anybody should bear
the of the rest.
No, I don't know if I think about it.
Now, that's really interesting.
You know, some vets saying, yes, I fought
in order to make that something that is OK,
even if I don't like it.
And other vets saying, no, no, that should
be against the law.
And then the follow up.
Now, this is really what I find maybe the
most interesting for folks who said, yes,
burning the flag should be against the law.
They were asked, what should the punishment
be?
What should the consequences be for burning
a flag?
Take a listen to this.
They should not be the same person to go to
Cuba, Russia, Germany, China.
Yeah, they might be stripped of citizenship.
Deported to Cuba, Russia, Germany or China,
now Germany's inclusion there is weird, I'm
guessing the reason I'm guessing they're sort
of saying like World War two era Germany.
I guess it's a Nazi reference.
But what's interesting is that Cuba, Russia
and China are certainly more the in the direction
of places where flag burning might also be
banned.
And what's very interesting is that this gets
us back to the idea of so many of the folks
who say, if you don't like it, leave it.
If you don't like X about the United States,
go somewhere else.
Typically, the places they think of going
to are not the places that actually make sense
politically, both for the people that are
on the right and the people that are on the
left when you start pointing to authoritarian
countries.
But in any case, that's sort of another another
discussion.
Let's look at a little more about what should
the punishment be.
The first thing came to change my mind.
I'm not going to say on that exportation expert,
would you go if you have to walk them through?
And it is nice this time of year with all
the time featherbed.
Yes, thank you so much.
I think anybody that is caught burning the
flag should be punished for this.
Get their ass on the spot there, incarcerate
people for the black flag, burning the black
lives matter.
Finally, come on and not do anything we put
on burning American flag.
This now brings back to black flag.
You think that's different?
No, I don't it's not national property burned
them, export them, not deport them, export
them like a sack of soybeans, death sentence,
hang them tar and feather, 30 days in jail,
a year in jail, beat them up, etc..
Extraordinarily authoritarian for the people
complaining that even banning someone on Twitter
is a restriction of First Amendment rights,
even though Twitter is not the government
deportation prison death for burning a flag.
That's what you call ignorant authoritarian
nationalism.
It's nationalistic in the idea of the flag
as this sacred thing.
It's authoritarian in that it imposes extraordinarily
authoritarian points of view or government
actions on people.
And it's ignorant in that it misunderstands,
you know, the reality of what is the First
Amendment, what is the difference between
a government limiting speech versus a Twitter
or Facebook enforcing terms of service?
Now, of course, legally burning a flag is
speech.
It's symbolic speech per Texas v. Johnson
in nineteen eighty nine.
There have been flag burning amendments proposed
over time to outlaw burning the flag.
But flag burning is legal.
This is interesting because you actually see
the split between more traditional conservatism
and Trumpy, an authoritarian faux populism
or as I just mentioned, ignorant authoritarian
nationalism.
That's a lot of isms, but it's a lot of incompetence
as well.
So you may need a lot of isms to describe
it.
Actual conservatives might dislike flag burning,
but they know that this is a very black and
white issue.
It's legal, it's speech, and it's fundamentally
American that it is legal to burn flags.
They don't have to like it, but they would
understand that the Trump cultists, the faux
populists, the authoritarian nationalists,
et cetera, Trump has said jail people for
burning the flag.
They are essentially as authoritarian as Trump.
So they go for it just like Donald Trump did.
And this will be a split that we're going
to have to track in the Republican Party over
the next couple of years.
And we're going to talk in the next story.
We're directly talking about this, but this
is definitely a division within the current
Republican Party.
Now, my perspective would be flag burning
is legal, should be legal.
There's nothing sacred.
My goal would be let's make this a country
where everyone is so proud and satisfied with
how it's being run that nobody feels the need
to burn a flag in protest.
That's my perspective on this.
And of course, it should be legal and it is
legal, period.